for six months of the year crystal blue  lagoons appear in what would otherwise  look like your average desert making LUN  sites Mary Ennis one of brazil's most  mysterious destination Linc's Marianas  is a national park located in Brazil  from January to June the area becomes  inundated with rainstorms the rainwater  collects between the sand dune creating  thousands of clear water lagoons  some of these pools reach over 300 feet  in length and can be over ten feet seats  with water temperatures as high as 87  degrees visitors come from far and wide  to experience the pristine conditions  but arriving at these pools is no easy  feat and renting a four-wheeler is a  must the right is rough as you need to  cross tight spaces and navigate through  rivers and puddles  when sois Marianas visitors must enjoy  these Falls while they can because come  dry season did spectacular landscape  vanishes and returns to its desert form  once again  [Music]